the debanking stuff is a sign that
there's going to be some kind of serious
financial crash and they're trying to do
everything to push everyone towards
towards digital currencies and they want
a central bank digital currency and I
was actually listening to some guy talk
about there's this uh Apple just
announced this bank account with four
percent interest and I'm hearing
everybody be like I have to set one of
those things up four percent interest
that's that's that's huge I mean
inflation's way worse than that if
you're tracking the real numbers but
four percent is big for a savings
account and so now I'm hearing that this
is causing an upset in the financial
industry to a certain degree at least
I'm I'm not a financial guy I don't know
for sure but that why get a CD at three
point eight or four percent if a savings
account with apple is better and you
don't gotta wait for it to to mature or
whatever and so we're just we're seeing
stuff like that and I don't know what
that really means all I know is I see
people saying they're concerned about it
we're seeing Banks collapse we're seeing
debanking and I'm wondering if the big
move is going to be get everybody onto
digital currency currencies big collapse
happens Central Bank digital currency
gets launched
I can't say whether or not that's the
actual plan but I know that nowadays
there are a lot more options for people
when it comes to banking Financial
technologies have really taken off
things like Bitcoin showed that digital
types of currencies uh can actually work
and so obviously you see banks that
exist coming up in companies now
obviously with apple doing it with
offering bank accounts or whatever
um you're gonna see more Innovations in
the financial technology sector unless
the government completely shuts it down
so I don't know that they're going to
but I would expect without a central
bank digital currency I would expect
more options and more possibilities for
people to come from the private sector
because that's what that's what happens
but what does that mean as you stretch
money across those different areas if
you have so many different options then
how does anything stay safe stable
because if you take money out of banks
then banks are not Stables so you have
to look at this and say okay well
somebody has to kind of say well there
has to be some control so that
everything's not crashing you're talking
to a Libertarian here kind of dude so
I'm like no just straight up no like I
think that there are all there are there
are tons of options for ways to save
your value things that you have you know
whether it be money or whether it be
Bitcoin different cryptocurrencies
there's a ton of different you know
currencies in the world that people can
say I think these are better than
dollars for whatever crazy reason they
come up with you can buy gold you can
buy silver there's already so many
different ways to store currency and
save currency and save value uh just a
few more Banks or more options that are
now new technologies I don't think
that's any kind of significant problem I
don't think it's a problem at all I
think that that that's something that we
can handle I mean people most people
that have a significant amount of wealth
it's usually in stocks we're frequently
in stocks and stuff like that in a in
owning companies so I don't know that I
don't know that it needs to be
controlled by the the Federal Reserve I
think that that the markets will control
all that kind of stuff so that's just my
take back to Twitter for a second do you
think we're going to see a lot of people
stop paying for Twitter to at least give
it some time to see how it plays out
or do they want that blue check really
bad no I think that it's I mean I I
don't know it'll be interesting because
for some people I think it's their
business and they feel like that's a
service they subscribe to and so maybe
they'll watch and see and then I think
that once they see the first the first
signs of what you're concerned about
that's when you'll see people just
immediately drop
it I was gonna say I think maybe that's
the appropriate response instead of just
canceling everything out right
basically just saying to Elon my viewers
this is thin ice and if we see one bad
move like we're skittish we are we are
running but for the time being I really
want I really want to believe I really
want Elon to succeed in this endeavor
and if the issue is he's looking at the
bottom line like we need advertisers and
this woman worked in the Trump
Administration I'm like okay she was in
the Trump Administration yeah okay well
I mean I mean Trump picked that's what
people are saying right I'm pretty right
exactly that's why I'm like I don't know
I think that you have to think of it
from she's a known Trump supporter
according to Vox
so she she would you would think that
doing this you would be very careful not
to immediately make changes and and make
a lot of people mad because you saw what
just happened with Bud Light I mean they
literally are giving a 15 rebate right
now with every case you buy you know
really yeah
it's a disaster for them but but if
that's the reaction why would they take
the chance of everybody dropping their
subscription which which I mean
obviously this happened with big
corporations just recently so it's quite
possible but like you said I think that
you wait and you see if this is what
happens then conservatives are not going
to hesitate they've made that clear now
we're just done with this woke stuff if
you're gonna do it we're out my favorite
thing about Twitter since Elon took over
is that he has brought back freedom of
speech to an extent which I think a lot
of people value and that's not
necessarily a conservative value it's
pretty crazy that people think that is
now and um the Lord Chris's remarks like
talking about uh what she said freedom
of speech not freedom of reach I wonder
what is deemed hateful like who's
defining that the big the big play for
the left is to argue that free speech is
conservative so that they can make
anything they don't like right wing and
then anything so so right means bad left
means good yep so from now on I'm just
going to call them right wing it's like
it's it's and I'm and I'm gonna say it's
always been the right that was anti-free
Speech free speech is like the ultimate
Rebel move yeah so they're all they're
all right far right well if you're not
on the left you're far right experience
even if you're on the left and you say
one thing out of line you're a far right
extremist now it doesn't take very much
to step out of line on the left
oh yeah just gotta call them far right
although left and right are relatively
meaningless these days just means like
which tribe are you in but that's what
they try to do and then how do you how
do you fight back against that when you
say I'm for free speech that well then
you're conservative the argument they're
making is free speech is a traditional
position and banning hate speech is the
progressive position right so you are
you are old and archaic if you support
the old way of doing things but but it's
also helpful to not teach history so we
just saw that the Proficiency in history
is at the lowest levels in the United
States ever so if you don't know what
happens when you ban speech if you don't
know that people were you know killed or
kept in prison because they went against
the king then you don't know why the
founding fathers were so adamant that we
had to be able to say whatever we want
even if they don't like it even if it's
burning the American flag if even if
it's something that seems so awful they
want you to be able to say it because
once you start to it's a slippery slope
once you start to take it away then
everybody it'll hurt them too that's the
funny thing it won't hurt them too I
feel like conservatives have become
liberal
in the literal sense of things like
Liberals are far left extremists not
really most of them are just ignorant
but then there's a lot of people who are
quote unquote liberal who are actually
far left and then conservatives are
adopting liberal positions so
conservatives saying something like well
if it's your flag you can burn it
whereas conservatives used to say you
shouldn't be allowed to burn the flag
Trump and many of the Trump supporters
still said you should not be allowed to
desecrate the flag but a lot of
conservatives are adopting more
libertarian positions or classically
liberal positions and I think that's one
of the intentions of the left is to
force conservatives leftward right so
they make the wheel rotate the far left
becomes moderate and conservatives
become Fringe then people who are center
right are now the far right and they
keep turning the wheel until the left is
considered moderate well I would argue
even school choice is liberal you're
saying people should have the ability to
choose that we should be able to let
parents make that decision on their own
and they're saying no no it has to be
our way you have to have kids in school
in the schools we choose even if the
schools totally failing the child they
must stay there we don't care what you
want for your kid and we don't care if
you want to have a future or an
education or opportunity we you must do
what we say that is not that that is not
a liberal
attitude is that you you have to conform
no I mean it's
the idea that liberalism or the idea the
ideals of liberalism have fallen so out
of favor with you know specifically
young people
um but I think there's too many of the
thought leaders that have been writing
books and papers and stuff for the past
30 years and influencing the teachers
and influencing the schools of Education
that's why you have kids that don't
understand you know that don't
understand anything about our our system
people don't understand the way that the
why you know things like freedom of
speech and stuff are important so I you
know I don't they're they're they're
cutting our our this country's youth
from the history yeah as you mentioned
they don't know history and then you see
there was this teacher who said
something about wokeness in the schools
so the students went out and protested
the teacher with communist Sons yeah and
this is how it starts people need to pay
attention to this because those kids in
10 20 years are going to be in politics
there is a maoist cultural revolution
going on in America right now but
people think because it doesn't happen
overnight it doesn't happen but it's
never overnight yeah I think something
that we recently spoke to someone who
was in she had she moved from China when
she was in her 20s and she'd gone
through the Revolution and she said they
started with the kids what they did was
they went to the kids and they got them
to believe and then the kids would turn
in the parents for wrong think and you
can see that already you see families
breaking up over cultural issues over
political issues in the United States
and you could see that next step of
children willing to go to the government
and say my parents are thinking the
wrong thing you need to go after them
you can present evidence and people will
still reject that I've been doing this
like been saying look this stuff and
blah blah blah and talking about that
stuff with my friends that are that are
historically liberals right Democrats
like I come from the music entertainment
world and so there's tons of producers
and and record Executives and and people
in bands and stuff that I'm familiar
with and most of them are basically the
default Democrat right and they aren't
aware that this is going on and then you
can show them and present evidence and
see look these are the parallels to what
went on in China when the cultural
revolution was getting started and here
Etc you can see this and and they just
refuse to believe it because there's
because it doesn't have that like
immediate happening right in front of me
right now that they expect to get that
they expect to see with a revolution
they don't realize that it's a slow
rolling kind of thing and trying to
convince them is incredibly hard it took
me or it took the uh the Bill Maher and
I think it was it wasn't the Elon Musk
thing it was Bill Maher talking about
his experience with or what he saw the
parallels between maoism and and the
woke on college campuses now when that
came out then a buddy of mine was like
yeah okay I can kind of see that but it
took it takes so much it takes someone
like Bill Maher who's basically a uh you
know an s-lib and and and saying that
kind of stuff limousine liberals yeah
you know it takes him to kind of be like
no
this is actually happening and I see the
parallels too thankfully he said it
because that is actually going to wake
up your typical liberals your default
Democrats because that's someone they
trust telling them that as opposed to
someone they don't trust telling them
that but I don't know that you know I
don't know that it has translated to
something where most people feel that
way I think one of the big ones that
wakes a lot of people up is when they
get called out for saying a woman is a
female or like we shouldn't have males
and female sports there are some really
obvious ones that you can't ignore are
obviously insane and like for me having
it affect my life and seeing it impact
other people's lives I know a lot of
women who were very much so on the left
and then saw this happen and were like
nope not anymore there's a line I mean I
really do feel like the left pushes
further and further until finally the
bubble pops but for for the most part
they keep it to a certain point where it
stays loving and that's the thing they
believe people believe it's loving you
know this is a kind way to do things
like everybody benefits from this we you
know everybody benefits if you don't let
people say hateful things that's what
they believe you know and then they say
it's hateful to say something like the
scientific research coming out of Europe
suggests that we should not be giving
children sex change surgery they say
that's hate speech it's like it's just
what that's what they're doing in Europe
I don't know you know I mean it was the
same thing with kids learning with masks
on Europe much earlier came out and said
we have to make sure that kids are
learning to speak that the speeches is
very clear that we can and and these
scientific studies came out but then you
know it was like we we weren't allowed
to say that I mean there are all these
things that as studies come out from
other countries we're slower to adopt
that thinking so that's very interesting
yeah but I think your average person is
like oh no hate speech good we shouldn't
be throwing slurs around but it's
playing out to a much more extreme way
this is what they do they will say
something like we just it's the modern
Bailey we're just saying that people
shouldn't be using slurs and then
everyone goes well we agree with that
then you come out you say something like
I have concerns about whether or not we
should be sterilizing children I hate
speech that's what we've been right and
so these default Libs who don't pay
attention I don't know what's going on
have no idea what they're actually
getting behind is like overt communism
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time